this was a coordinated onslaught of
precision-guided missiles Russia hit all
these cities the length and breadth of
Ukraine striking civilian infrastructure
and it claims military targets though we
haven't seen much evidence of that in
Kiev it hit a busy intersection outside
the university hitting cars and killing
civilians a park was struck narrowly
missing a children's playground and
Russia targeted a landmark pedestrian
bridge though the missile missed its
Mark there followed an attack on this
the Kirch bridge between Russia and
illegally occupied Crimea it was opened
by Putin and used to supply his war in
Ukraine it's been left badly damaged off
the attack blamed on Ukraine over the
weekend and that could have a major
impact on the war because it means that
Russian forces in the red area here are
running out of crucial supplies
especially fuel analysts say they are
now operating on borrowed time if we're
talking about the ability to
maneuver I drive places and I think we
are talking
um days into very short weeks and can
this stand and fight they could sustain
that for a long period of time likely
through the winter time if Ukraine has
um Russia on the move I they are
dominating the battle space they're
pushing them back forcing the Russians
to maneuver and there's no diesel to
maneuver the armor with it's highly
likely the armor will be left in place
Putin has said there will be more days
like this if Ukraine continues what he
calls terrorist attacks but his forces
have only a limited number of these
Precision guided weapons they may not
have the means to follow through on that
threat